[Musik]
wir gehen heute gemeinsam nach yoursgar
in die Türkei dort gibt es nämlich ein
kleines Dorf das heißt checkerek und wir
haben den Bürgermeister des Dorfes oder
der Stadt kennengelernt und der
Bürgermeister ist wirklich ein ganz
toller es seit drei Jahren schon im Amt
und setzt sich dort wirklich für
Frauenrechte ein also in einem Land in
dem teilweise noch sehr viel Tradition
und Kultur herrscht andererseits aber
auch sehr modern ist und es ist
wunderschön zu sehen wie er dort die
Frauen unterstützt er möchte nämlich
dass Frauen nicht einfach nur zu Hause
sitzen sondern dass sie sich frei
entfalten können dass sie arbeiten
können vor allem dass sie ihren
Interessen nachgehen können und
unterstützt dort deswegen die
Fraueninitiative die hat seine Frau
gegründet Eminem und sie ist dort der
Vorstand und die Frauen dort sind
wirklich der Hammer die sind kreativ sie
sind fleißig sie sind wahnsinnig
intelligent und sie haben sich alle
zusammengeschlossen und gesagt wir
wollen einfach was tolles tun wir wollen
etwas bewirken und was bewegen